I am Andy hi we're get Wolfram research
and my talk is about Wolfram prisoner
tones
this talk is about Wolfram residuals and
of course the irony of making a
presentation with presenter cool is this
kind of a presenter tools was first
released in Mathematica 11.3 and with
version 12 there's been a lot of updates
especially in the back end with the
speed I don't know if any one of has
used it eleven point three there was a
little sluggish with typing with version
twelve that's pretty much gone away
a lot of good dynamic improvements so
just kind of an introduction so this
will be probably quick just what we'll
be covering today what is presenter
tools and demos and features talk about
the future plans
a few implementation details which are
great for developers and then I'm still
kind of hungry so if anyone wants to go
to lunch that would be great
what is presenter tools it's pretty I
mean the name kind of says it all it's
offering toolkit that helps you author a
presentation as well as present a
notebook in whether it's in a situation
like this where you're presenting to
using projectors and or whether you're
creating video though Camtasia videos
for YouTube or whatever
it'll help you do quite a bit of that
some of the features responsive content
scaling we have new things style sheets
palettes author notes which are a really
good feature home for me especially that
you can type notes in your notebook your
presentation notebook
can tighten notes to yourself and then
as you're presenting they don't show on
the screen but they show for you as the
presenter so that you can remind
yourself or say don't forget to talk
about version 12 speed of dynamic more
things configurable keyboard controls
previous/next you can assign to
different keystrokes lots of different
modes of editing you can turn on and off
different window elements or windows
size optionally copy and paste slide
slide copy things no not today
ah not today but this is so this
notebook was created with presenter
tools I used it as the authoring some of
the features as in presentation mode
which I'm doing now in the upper right
corner there's a menu it shows you can
use the menu to navigate if you want to
as well as keyboard but you can choose
different options there's the option for
if you like the standard navigation bar
of at the top if I can do this look at
the same time the outline which is kind
of what you're saying which is a feature
that we will have not today but in the
future there is an outline palette you
can show your thumbnails create you know
different size but this is something
where one would
grab slide four move it to slide nine
reorder etc not today
but yes that's coming in a feature that
I certainly like myself so in the pallet
do that or the menu in presentation the
presentation controls this dealing with
multiple screen you can choose which key
does your first previous next and
presentation which is helpful
by default your arrow keys left and
right arrow is what will navigate you
through your sites so I'm pressing right
arrow touring the slides you can change
that according so let's get out of this
and I'll start demoing some of the real
nice features in Mathematica new you can
see so file new presenter notebook
brings up a chooser where you can choose
different themes we have all these
different themes that you can choose
structural you know whether you want
flush left left right center or all
these different structural looks as well
as the color variations optionally for
any of these optionally you can choose a
font set or a color set that you like
more than the default down below is a
little preview on what it would look
like with the choices that you've made
you can choose whether or not to
pre-fill your presentation when you're
when you click choose prefilled your
presentation with content so you can
kind of see what we anticipate you would
use it or you can just start with a
blank notebook which we'll do now
because I littell is my favorite ice
cream so we'll do this straight vanilla
when you choose create you get this yeah
so when you start with a new
presentation you get this and at the top
you get a new toolbar which has your
inserting new slides and insert styled
cells your basic formatting commands
whether you want what font choices you
want bullets italic etc your window size
is one of the toolbar menus so if you're
if you know that you're going to present
at a certain ratio you can choose so
that you're starting to format your talk
using the ratio that you will be using
on your talk there's a menu for
different window elements if you want to
turn off and on during all of them so
you can use the keyboard commands to
insert of course just like any notebook
but there is also your style menu so
these are section cells so how you slide
one like in the keyboard command to do
another section cell I like sections
more in titles
it's I choice a lot of people like
different styles for different headings
in their talk
everything's there you can use whatever
you're like it's perfectly up to you are
the same the same as in a default
notebook so it's same across them all
so as I'm creating this I'm noticing
right now since not since I'm not using
title music section that the font size
is going to be too small for people back
there to see a normal presentation
although these are gigantic so you can
probably see these over at Walgreens so
we can use the font scaling to increase
the font size to something that would be
readable in the back rows if we like
this as a heading we can also do you
know italic whatever we would like to
see as you're heading for your slides
and one really nice feature about
presenter tools is that you have all
these buttons and and whatnot to format
your text but now if you like what you
see once I've changed options let's see
if I can so up at the top by there's a
little button there that's lit
highlighted once I've changed options on
a cell that light goes off because all
I'm sorry that it asks you do you want
to apply the changes you've just made to
that cell do you want to apply it back
to the style sheet so if you're playing
it back to the style sheet then you can
use that all those same options the next
time you're using that style so it's a
embedded style sheet so it's the style
sheet that's associated with this
notebook so we're gonna embed the style
sheet into so
if I click by click yes then I get a
dialog that shows me the options that
I've applied to that cell and I can
choose whether or not I want all of them
or which ones to be applied back to the
style sheet I'll go ahead and choose
them all and so what's happened is that
all those options are now in that style
for section in the style sheet so this
second cell second section cell
automatically inherits the options from
the style sheet so it - appears it's the
same as the first and if I unform at all
the options that I've applied to that
cell are gone have been removed from the
cell and are in the style sheet it's all
so if I create another section from the
menu or type
whichever doesn't matter let's do this
line three then I get the same as before
if I if I want to tweak it a little bit
more and say well there's just not
enough space or the alignment I really
like a line right well that's too far to
the right so now I want to nudge it a
little bit so there's these nudging
buttons which dynamically change your
cell margins for yourself so you can
move your content around the screen
similar to a PowerPoint ish presentation
and then you can apply those there's a
dialog again you can apply those back to
the style sheet
and they're gone from that one and it
didn't get picked up okay well so
authoring notes which are very are very
good for to myself as well as others
probably so you can from the menu too
many monitors here sorry so you can from
the menu up here you can choose side
note to create one of these or you can
choose side code I'll just copy this
paste it below here say this is another
note to myself and I'll choose and I'll
create another one and say yes I'm still
angry angry if you want to put code
I'll see what this looks like in a
minute paste some code in
and evaluate now so I have this I have
three slides with side notes notes to
myself but right now there's no if I say
if I click present it goes full screen
one slide because there's no marker
there's no divisions yet except for the
one I can end up at the top on the right
to the button there's a menu which you
can use to show your different modes you
want the slideshow but not full screen
which I personally like more you can do
that so you it's the same visual
appearance just not full screen I can
grab the end here so the responsiveness
your kind of single sourcing
so you have the choice at the top I can
say end presentation so on the button
itself on the right there's a little
arrow and you can choose a slideshow
presentation scrolling presentation so
slideshow is what I chose so it's the
same as the full screen but right so I
do want them the slides right right so I
need dividers right so which is a great
point so what I want to do is I want to
put slide dividers and markers so that
slide
is actually a slide not just a regular
so if I go to slide break defaults the
button at the top I can click I get a
dialog that says which cell style would
I like a slide break to appear above so
I like sections not piled so much so
I'll do sections and then I'll say set
so then what happens here is I've added
slide breaks above each of my sections
off so I can choose whatever style I
want i can choose input to be my slide
break style and this will automatically
insert them for you you can by hand go
through and search them yourself this is
just kind of a something to get you up
and running quicker especially if you're
going from if you already have a
notebook and you want a slide show out
of it then you can go through and say
okay I've got 45 section cells
I want 45 slides I do that and go and
then it's already composed for you
so it's kind of a it's not magnification
but it's just a temporary you can use
magnification if you like the kind of
the hope is that as you're composing
your slide what I can do now and like
four minutes what I can do now is is
through the style palette which is one
of the menu items style to those how it
is I can go ahead and increase things if
I want for on site if I want someone to
surely be able to see something that
kind of that zoom is not missus Ponson
is kind of true right all notebooks have
magnification settings you can go ahead
and as a temporary you can go well you
know I spent this much time making the
talk but I got to the place and you know
this is not big enough a quick fix like
you're saying is to just pop the
magnification in the menus magnification
is still there this is just a notebook
like any other notebook quick fixes
if you like through the option inspector
yeah do anything true true but I don't
disagree so I've added these notes to
myself as well as a plot so as I'm
showing the audience so here's the
here's what the audience is seeing
here's what I'm seeing on my on my
screen I can go back to slide one I have
Oh some note to myself I need to talk
about you know getting a Snickers after
I get out of here oh there's this
equation I need to do so if I if I click
then the equation is pasted into the
notebook if I if I right click then it's
pasted and evaluating so you can use
these for various a very helpful
step-by-step or if you're talking just
lots of different instances where you
would like to have more of a narrative
and wanting to paste things from your
notes into without sitting here and
typing like I did before I have a
computer here I'm mirroring so I've got
I got this is one screen and I've got
another screen here it's not not mirror
it's a extended so what you're seeing
here is not what I'm seeing here it's
I'm seeing a whole different thing here
so I have a little screen yes sir
but that's kind of one of the one of the
features is that you can present have
your notes and do it all at the same
time
correct correct
so in I mean I can here's my uh I can
show you right now so these are notes I
made to myself for my talk I'm talking
about the chooser dialog what to choose
etc the notebook itself back here to our
screen that was on
I don't know how to get back to the
nursing well the original notebook is
there's another secondary well anyway so
right so these are the original notebook
presentation that I had I have lots of
notes to myself in it just like I showed
before these this is the presenter note
side note to myself that I made for my
presentation so it's showing this
computer the presentation is on today I
guess we're out of time already
it's kind of fast so lots more they're
presented Wolfram calm slash presenter
tools lots of information if you want to
connect with me I'm here and around talk
to you more about your presentations or
how to best use Brasseur tools it's a
great feature lots of documentation
coming lots of more examples more in
version 12 still some bugs obviously but
lots more features incoming 12 so thank
you appreciate it
[Applause]